We don't want you here that's the message
of around two hundred Tijuana residents protesting
the arrival of thousands of Central American
migrants.
The demonstration underlines the growing tension
here.
The protestors accuse the migrants of forcing
their way into Mexico, and of being ungrateful
for the help they're offered.
We don't want our government to support this
farce.
We all know it's a sham.
They're just bringing their problems here.
They've just come here to use us.
Our government is spending a lot of money
on them although there are many poor people
here already.
The protest march targeted the city's sports
stadium, which has been turned into a makeshift
shelter for the migrants.
A police barrier kept them out, but the people
inside were trapped in the stadium all day.
We're not leaving the stadium because we don't
want to instigate any violence.
We fled violence and don't want to cause more
of it."
Locals threw stones at the migrants twice
in the last week.
The people who arrived with the caravan are
frightened.
Darío Suanso, migrante hondureño
We're in great danger.
They come from areas of Mexico that don't
want us here.
They're disguised as garbage men, they're
armed and want to attack us.
They hit a child on the head when they threw
stones at us.
The flare-up of xenophobia in Mexican towns
along the migrants' route is unprecedented.
In Tijuana, locals are angry because the city
is ill-equipped to deal with the influx of
people -- who sleep on the streets and rely
on aid organisations for food.
When someone is handing out chocolate everyone
crowds around.
People are desperate, they've had a torturous
journey and do it to survive.
There's no food in the shelters.
Racially charged comments from local politicians
have heightened tensions.
A prominent example is Tijuana's Mayor Juan
Manuel Gastélum, who called the migrants
"lazy".
A deputy of the state governor drove home
his law and order message at the protest:
Our government and society will welcome them
and help them, but only in keeping with the
law.
Residents here are very generous, but they
want rules to be upheld."
Such rhetoric has done nothing to cool the
hotheads on the streets of Tijuana.
With more and more migrants crowding into
the city, there is plenty of scope for the
protests to grow.